is Bruce Smith set to join us there
around fritzy Bruce can you hear me I
can hear you bandits it's faint but I
can hear you all right let me get the
full introduction here hall-of-famer
former Buffalo Bills and Washington
Redskins defensive lineman and and I
found all times sack leader 11 Pro Bowls
and won Defensive Player of the Year a
couple of times and of course a big TV
star after what we saw with a celebrity
Family Feud on Sunday now when did you
shoot that Bruce damn first of all
thanks for having me on your show and
it's always good to see you since the
last time we play now we played in Tahoe
a couple of years ago Bruce had a golf
bag that rivaled rodney dangerfield in
in Caddyshack and I felt bad for your
caddie because that guy labored all day
carrying that bag that looked like it
weighed about 50 pounds though but yeah
we had fun that day with jaws yeah we
had we had a great time out there we
actually build the show in the middle of
February this year and it it was quite
the reunion you know anytime you get
multiple Hall of Famers together with
with the same type of personalities it's
always a great time and I got to tell
you the family feud and LPA put together
a great list Orlando pace Michael Irving
Kevin Green and CC Chris Carter we had a
fabulous time so when did you know like
did you have any idea that this was
going to come out I'm sorry that that
the video clip with Steve Harvey was
going to come out that on social media
we were we were made aware that that the
show was going to come out but during
the taping of it we had to stop the show
multiple times because of my wild picks
my wild pitch answer and Steve RV did
what only Steve Harvey can do
yeah hit it out of the ballpark okay did
this happen before so that that's not
the first time you did something on
family feud that you had to restart
again because he you it was one time it
was a technical difficulty on their
fault
okay the second time it was the second
and third time it was my fault because
we the answer because everyone was in
stitching's and they were laughing so
hard and Steve just stopped the whole
show and get about a 15 minute comedy
session for the audience and I think we
just couldn't stop laughing it was so
funny and and and the way Steve response
was and the facial expressions that he
gave it was priceless well this is how a
portion of it sounded Bruce Smith on
celebrity Family Feud if Captain Cook
was moonlighting as a handyman
he might replace his hook with what to
hammer a penis okay Bruce what were you
thinking that was a problem I couldn't
think at that point intact you know
there's something about there is
something about a time clock and a
buzzer that it makes you become confused
when you're running out of time and you
don't have an answer I gave the
number-one answer
originally and then when that buzzer
went off a couple of times I guess I
kind of patty of all the things in
convention in a toolbox you listen to
penis
hey hey but Dad balance let's go back a
little bit okay as we were filming the
show
there were multiple questions where all
they talked about was sex there Michael
Irving was talking about
his wife and and he she was playing the
role of an assistant in the office there
was another question pertaining to 2:00
to 6:00 and so I was already hot-wired
to potentially give that answer I just
needed you know the time and space what
kind of reaction have you gotten if
you're a former teammates beat me up a
little bit oh my goodness where they
they they were in stitches they just
they were dying laughing while the show
was going on I kept telling them that
it's going to get better it's going to
get better and and there's a climax
that's coming here the real talk about
this is you know we're living in some
difficult times right now whether it's
the the virus the racial tensions and
and and so many other difficulties in
life everyone needs a good laugh and I
think that's I think this this provided
a good laugh for everyone that watches
family dude alright I'm gonna call a
false start penalty and I'm gonna ask
you the question again so you can get it
right okay all right sounds good okay if
Captain Hook was moonlighting as a
handyman
he might replace his hook with what tool
Hey yeah we were joking about it
yesterday if we were working on a car
and I asked you to take something out of
the toolbox I would be afraid what you
would have grabbed given your answer on
yeah family feud so yeah some of my guys
text me backs it we we can't use this
two above I got I got you it right at
200 sacks all time is that right yeah
that that's the regular season
there's I think 14 or somewhere around
14 more in the in the playoffs but yes
200 career regular sex if I could show
one and I said that was Bruce Smith just
one sack which one would you pick oh
there's there's some very memorable ones
and and some of some of my favorites
obviously you know that the names that
that really stick out or Dan Marino and
John Elway and Joe Montana but you know
one of the highlights was the safety and
end zone against the Giants and Jeff
Hostetler okay and the Super Bowl I've
got you sack ken O'Brien more than any
other quarterback with the Jets
yes that's I'm right yes they they were
in the division we played them twice a
year and and so I I became very familiar
being in their backfield I'm trying to
think who didn't you get you there's to
be one long no I mean a long laundry
list of players that I did get
quarterback that is true I got them all
in front of me I got them all in front
of me oh wow yeah bubby Brister Aaron
Brooks Scott Campbell Cody Carlson Kelly
Stouffer Sean Moore are some of these
guys still alive
Donovan McNabb Chad Hutchinson Bucky
Richardson but Bernie Kosar me like this
is like a who's who of the position
there yeah how would you do if you
played now in your prime how many sacks
well I think since since the game has
evolved and they're throwing the ball
roughly 30% more yeah in this era of
football I think I would do extremely
well particularly if I played in a 4-3
defense and particularly
there was another dominant pass rusher
that that was on the line of scrimmage
with me I playing in that three-four
defense obviously it's very difficult to
get to the quarterback because it's
easier to get a double team or a second
or third hat on that dominant defensive
player but I think I would fare very
well in this this arrow football no I'm
sure you would too if invited will you
go back on family feud
absolutely absolutely
I might give you another dude you look
great
you look like you could give me maybe
five to ten plays that's about it hey
thanks for being a good sport and I
wasn't surprised you came on and I
enjoyed our time when we played golf
together and keep smiling Bruce it's
great to talk to you same here dad let
Dan let's let's spread a little love
around the world man we need it right
now thank you sir and I'll just stay
away from your toolbox but thank you
very alright that's the great Bruce
Smith Hall of Famer 200 career sack